apartment counselors do not believe who
has advised that she might be like
emergency evacuation announcement in the
event of a fire or other emergency and
please exit the building in northern
manner to the assembly point which is
located in market the fire exit is
reason to pay for green fire exits one
please do not delay the evacuation by
collecting any buildings do not use the
litter the premises must not be
reinserted into the fire danger people
you will appear and please only against
the law to smoke on these premises
please save this meeting will be audio
recorded can I please ask band members
just turn their mobile phone to silent
please apologies for absence
we have apologies from the councillors
Dre and for the capsule williams
councillor quicken is substituted all
canceled right non-members attendance
evening council uses point counselor
Weston
including members are circulated there
is a recommendation which is
council buster Little John Paul so if
you've got any comments you'd like to
make speaking of nothing to tell in
terms of you know the report itself
which which members would have seen I
think perhaps is worth mentioning that
the status to understand that approach
to member training across local
authorities and rock clubs approaches
developed from a combination of
decisions over a few years ago the
Standards Committee include member
training with in agreement all beaters
got much broader responsibilities but it
includes member train that was to
decision a few years ago and
requirements associated with achieving
the externally measured charter for
elected member development again was
something that's driven it's over the
years whilst there are many requirements
associated with that charter or the
words associated with into the council
no longer hulls hubs the Charter
chairman that's what I'd like to I just
say thank you
and they encourage any members any
questions I've got a counselor mr.
Menton it's not so much a question as an
observation like this so considering the
report was probably something that I did
do I think there's always room for
improvement even though we may have held
a chance along it seems to me that if
we're going to improve attendance at
training apart from the management ones
which of course has a fairly fairly good
then I think we do need to make some
changes to improve the extent of member
involvement in the choice of of subjects
that are put to training I know that
members are asked to comment at the time
of the feedback at the end of the immune
support training year but the report
actually admits that that's not very
good now either so given those two
things I'd like to see a situation
improved I'd like to see some form of
formal connection between members
generally and the standards committee
members because if there was that
connection that I think they'd be
greater input stands committee on the
presentation of the recommendations for
report for future training but on the
other hand it would be better if it was
something that was given input before
that report came forward so I've got
nothing specific to recommend except to
say I think
we need to improve that connection
improve that connection and
responsibility for standards committee
members to be better connected to the
thoughts of members and to have that in
such a way that it would inform the
officers report in the first case the
other alternative and maybe this not an
alternative maybe it's an addition it
could be that group leaders get better
input from from members than them there
are many others and maybe some form of
panel could be could be put together to
help inform that process of deciding on
the subjects for the following or the on
coming year so I've got two suggestions
one is some form of broome leaders panel
which may well improve the communication
between members and the training program
and also some sort of better connection
or maybe responsibility for the
standards committee members to go and
seek out exactly what members want to
want to have in their training program
we did have a recent change as you know
the mandatory training for failing was
was changed at almost an 11th hour and
the reason that that was member input
because as the cook Wade was with me I
think others were are also it was
certainly recognized that we had a major
piece of piece of work as individual
members to consider the provision of the
local plan and the process through it
and considering the evidence but there
were lots of new members who didn't even
know what the evidence actually was and
what the implications were so the
informal meeting of the planning policy
subcommittee asked the assistant
director for planning regeneration to
consider abandoning or postponing the
subject that he'd chosen and
interpolating something for the next one
that would actually benefit members and
the working in the council and I think
that's a great example for the reason
why we need greater member input I
welcome ugly other members is thank you
thank you
I can generally echo Casa mr. mason's
points of view I mean in the time I've
been on the council the attendance at
training sessions has generally
deteriorated I personally think that a
lot of the subject matter is not
relevant to the member role and is
actually more relevant to the officer
role and I'm sure that members are
interested in those subjects but the
relevance should be member orientation
more than anything and I certainly think
that members should have a much greater
input and I think the method for that
would be and it should be through the
standards committee that said I think
the whole looking of the the training
members training it seems to be slightly
dated and looking back at the years when
these decisions were taken and the input
I think that perhaps the standards
committee should do in two aspects one
would be the mandatory training and is
that necessary and if so is it necessary
to that degree because a lot of it is
repetition there's two aspects of that
in itself as the aspects of newer
members whose
they need training and there's aspects
for the more experienced members that
probably don't need the repetition and
it's not necessarily helpful so I think
that needs to be looked at to expect
leavin may end up with the same
situation but members should be asked if
they think those mandatory sessions are
necessary why it should be debated with
and the standards is a good place to
base it because we have independent
members on there is a very difficult
point of view and thing is the if you
like the voluntary attendance courses
which are recommended and that my
office's decided my office has
recommended my offices but I would much
prefer to see these decided by members
with obviously officer input if I feel
that there's a change in the legislation
or if there's a change in practice that
we need to know but we should be
generally aware of it and we should be a
capable of saying yeah as members that
okay we need perhaps specific training
at the moment we're sitting through
training which she thought often
inappropriate and not fit the purpose
and I don't like saying that I'm not
saying that like because somebody's very
good she has worsened over the periods
and I think the older serving members
would probably a sector that the
relevance and the quality of training is
not what it used to be and I think the
whole thing needs to be looked at and
remember laid with however that's done
through through either group that has
not through Estonia's committee nor
through I think it just came back to
that these forms that returned my
understanding is when these forms were
returned in the past with requests for
training they were ignored which is why
that the reforms are not being sent back
because members are aware that it has no
import
so we have to listen to members as well
not just ask and file but ask and listen
thank you
Thank You chairman yeah just really just
pick up picking up a point on council
mr. myson
made in relation to an example he gave
related to the planning that proposed
planning training and the sub-problem
planning policy subcommittee meeting or
the one I would attend that meeting I
was subbing for councillor Hughes on
there and I think that's a very good
example of where officers were focusing
on our particular plan that they had but
in terms of what was happening at that
particular period coming leading up to a
big important aspect of planning that's
coming up with the documents coming
forward for the evidence to do with the
issues and options document that's
coming long this was obviously a perfect
opportunity to get as many counselors to
be in a position to understand what is
ultimately a very complicated process to
get them to understand as much as
possible about that process before it
goes into full council you know there
may be many members
who have been on this council for a
while and have been through the previous
process but there's this significant
number that happen and that includes
myself so council Mason's point about
that is very well made at the meeting
and I think it's a perfect example where
members input will help to make the
training much more appropriate to the
work that they've directly got to be
involved in Thank You chair just a
couple points on echoing qasimi's makes
and his views on I hope I'm wrong but
I've always had the feeling that
Pretender the forms on training that
they they've been ignored very rarely
has anything changed I think that time
in training when I was quite brutal
about one course in particular I think
lots of members were quite brutal about
the same course and I think things may
be changed a but to actually have
noticed we can be also including phone
calls to us one of the assistant
directors Betty as well so it was quite
brutal that's the only time I've ever
done anything change otherwise any
requests or any comments seems were
being ignored and certainly no one's
ever come back to me to say to ask me
questions about what I might have put on
the forms or not Wonderful's
a way to get more forms may be to these
very old-fashioned I would have to hunt
for and locally
what an obvious are supposed to find him
in my office but envelope the stands
post them back is for the the only one
it seems a bit laborious my baby online
that's a simple one I'm through talking
like that I've never got the second week
all the other center for sunlight it is
useful the other point we're not looking
at these course is it we've said in
three point four as well as men but
input the leadership teams asked for
details of topics I Beatrice know how
many of the topics put forward on page
eight went to leadership saying Henry
pollute my members and how many actually
succeed on the cultures that I've I've
seen come forward more recently it's a
very interesting some good but they they
have the sensitive Airport for my
officers to help officers rather than
afford to help members personally to
save different authorities came thank
you think approach is some actually do
purely involved group leaders and
members interacting with group leaders
others may involve a committee I think
the standard skin which is quite rare
but it has been you know said this
business positives around around a
committee committee holding something so
nothing to you know
there's this various ways of attacking
it and the way it's been done it's being
done now it isn't necessarily in
hopefully the best way for the authority
it's just around just got a couple of
questions when you own the report 3.2 it
talks about how many fold return this
specifies only 14 forms return last
count which dramatically down from over
eighty percent return would it be
feasible to make that mandatory that
just have to return those bonds I think
the problem if not what women remember
remember training and including
mandatory training and Rockford's quite
rare in in having devised a magic train
system but but anything mandatory around
training can't actually be being forced
the only recourse is at the end of the
day when it comes to committees perhaps
not you know having some system where
where you don't get a vote but there's
no there's no recourse I mean again I
think I mean there's been suggestions
about group leaders and and if some
authorities if a group leader
bite into and is happy that training is
suitable to you know for the membership
then that's that's the better route you
know then I would save and try to
enforce something that at the end of the
days on your foursome and probably gives
the wrong ethos because it's it's it's
it's about internal workings and getting
the the corporate center right rather
than decision making it's it's the bit
before that you know also resource
implications it says there about the
budget for six and a half thousand just
does that increase decrease with that
set amount it's gone down in in recent
years it's been quite targeted that said
I mean the last Thursday the the
committee made a decision that might
help the resource solid affinities in
terms of adjusting me training if
attendance isn't and at a certain at a
certain level
it's separate from the review committee
training budget it's not an unreasonable
figure it's it's it's a it's suitable
for what the sort of train that's this
love tank and the figure of six and
obviously the moment someone from
trained in this provided is extended to
parishes yeah and fee is charged is that
all those the income from that is
anything that was included in that the
the income from parishes is marginal
it's that that that's some Michelle than
this you know
now some isn't really made up very much
of perishing communities 1,000 pounds
plus 30 40 pounds again yeah we got
three we'd have another hundred 20 added
to that Thank You counsel here just to
be really informative on the parish side
of it I understand that parishes can
send one member to a training course
cream if they want to spend any
additional and if they transfer me just
for my support that's the policy at the
moment it's something that the Standards
Committee could look at but that's the
policy yeah
counselor do you pull in Cantonese I'm
just on the subject of parishes do they
complete the feedback forms and how do
they value the training it's not being
taken to be you ever talk to that to the
parishes that those that attend to on
behalf of parishes do they complete
forms Michelle the youth they complete
the feedback form at the end of the
course district members will that they
don't they don't complete an assessment
form in
because it's not designed for parishes
they're just invited coming on to
appropriate words counselors imagine
Thank You mr. chair of allow me to come
back I think there's two aspects that
need clarification one is the feedback
forms a 20 down but who sees them and
you don't see that all the standards
committee and yet we're technically
approving the training program so I
think there was a concern they had the
the feedback seems to go into a black
hole of some way and regarding budget
I think perhaps Michelle couldn't
clarify this paper my recollection was
there was also a mountable it was about
five hundred pounds that the members
could apply for for one-off training
sessions if all group leaders approved
yet I'm not quite sure the amount that
it's perhaps the greatest could if they
have the authority and that that follows
me I don't know if that's within this
six and a half thousand I thought was
additional could have an answer to that
question before 1500 pounds we think
that that is taken out of the six and a
half thousand okay thank you no I knew
there was something there that haven't
been mentioned I would like the
recommendation bought it to be
more positive mr. chairman and if the
committee
sounded agrees I would like to propose
that the committee resolves that the
standards committee re-examine some
mandatory training sessions and also
ways of involving members in determining
members training I'm sorry
counselor mrs. Mason can you elaborate
on that
when you say extends committee mandatory
training in what sense do you mean when
mandatory training isn't mandatory the
purpose of law it's been made mandatory
by this council so I think going back
then it was mainly nothing 2008-2009 and
planning mandatory was major thinking
I'm not sure 2010 perhaps but it's been
quite a normal before that was
determined and I think we ought to
examine I'm not suggesting we need to
change it I think we ought to explore it
see if it needs to be changed see if it
needs to be reduced or increased because
if the training is more irrelevant we'll
get more attendance and other people
that do attend will be more involved and
if they're more involved they'll learn
more what we're not talking about when
we talk about manually remove - on the
mandatory training and people and I'm
guilty of it we're sitting there and
we're disengaged what we need if we're
going to have mandatory training we need
to have really valuable training that
members participating and get value from
so I think we need to just examine if we
need them how many we need them and the
structure just have a look at it we may
determine that what we have is perfectly
fit for purpose we might decide that so
I'm at least tweaking we might decide
that there's different mandatory
training requirements for new members
members but none of that has been
explored in recent years and I think
that's what I'm looking for for that and
the second part of resolution is quite
clear to find ways of involving members
particularly members of standards
committee we suggest in deterring
members training and I think if we get
more involvement from members in
determining the training then we will
get a better uptake and we will get
better educated and informed councils
which is very limited and we can't we
can't make people attended we've got to
make it so they want to attend
okay I understand with the vanity
training obviously that would be monkey
training works on the aspects that are
playing in their lives in an appeal we
had quite important and I was also good
to believe that if you've done it one
year a second if your experience or if
you had done it a year before
would you and a councilor unit unless we
have to go the second year that's what I
understood and then have the new members
who are new members mandatory training
know that unfortunately that's not the
case which is why there's a problem the
licensing training even if it's exactly
the same training the same training has
to be done every year right I mean I'm
not saying that it's a good or bad thing
I'm just saying it's something that the
next we explored probably more with you
know getting input from members some of
those committees I think the pills
training is the same but members have to
attend every year when the mandatory
training for planning at the moment is
that you can't miss two sequential
training sessions but you couldn't miss
one of us very relevant so it is
something that needs to be looked at
I'm not suggesting that there's a
necessity for change but I do think
there's a necessity for review okay I
understand that
thank you very much and members
it remembers would you like me to repeat
itself as I can give me the exact
equation opposed yes it was proposed
that the committee resolves that the
Standards Committee very examines the
mandatory training sessions and also
investigate ways of involving members in
determining member training sessions
counselor mr. Esmond I've only got one
suggestion of addition and it's a
request if you like for this committee
to consider would we like Sanders
committee to come back to us having
raised the issue and made the
recommendation that is I think it's
funny as follows we'll do we wanted to
go straight to full counsel from from
standards cause any members I mean I
think personally I would prefer to I
think it would be better for people to
the standards committee first was to be
same as laddies visually it's going to
stand out anything to review make sure
it standards committee come back to the
mutability or should he go direct to
full council probably that's it so we
can tack that on the bottom being can't
come back to review until the stairs we
didn't meet it we were talking about
what series so that's that's what when
it's going it to be remembers in
agreement the chip terms is just just a
couple of observations just just on
items
at this point I mean firstly the
Standards Committee could technically
determine these things without recourse
to full council a committee the
committee could do that or it could
recommend on or come back says secondly
the Standards Committee potentially may
be in the ocean with the Chairman but I
think the sort of recommendations
consideration to a committee meeting in
advance of you know I think the next
ones were quite quite a way off and to
get to grips with this subject you know
perhaps one you know at an earlier point
that would also allow a feed into
possibly into the next municipal years
so that these things that you know if
there is a decision made it's it's this
year but that's just they're just
observations Jim sorry you just clarify
exactly what you're saying exactly asked
the committee could if those
recommendations and the standards from
here and the standards committee
considered them they could determine
them without recommending on to full
council that would be possible and the
other thing is that I don't believe you
should I don't think as the Standards
Committee schedules end of March well
this is the it would be possible to and
probably was recommendations around
member training worth worth doing that
and and bring out always being discussed
so that something's in place you know
two things chair mats that was just
observations
in German if it helps I'm quite happy to
add on to the resolution that a special
studies Committee being convened to
examine this aspect so that if any
decisions can be implemented but in the
next training community Supriya if the
Chairman is happy with that and then I
think that covers that and I think he'll
sir
houses are aware that the Standards
Committee can make their own
determination but as this has come up at
review I do think we need to see just
see them they're satisfied with the
result
okay so because there the recommendation
members for the specific meeting of the
standards committee which the Chairman
is in agreement with our members happy
for that as well too bad it looks at
recommendation yes okay Thank You
councillor mr. Mason I'm glad you asked
for clarification I'm not sure if we got
it so I'm gonna ask what I'm gonna make
it a supposition if you like more shall
we say my interpretation many there are
many committees are what they call
Committees of four council standards
committee I believe is one the best of
borders another
I even think planning policies will come
to that later so of course they
committee report council can make its
own decision we're referring to full
council but when you're considering a
training program for the whole council I
think it would be a little amiss of
standards committee to not to go to full
council on this matter that is the sort
of thing to do this on board with the
investment fall can make a decision on
matters and it feels comfortable than it
will but in in recent in recent months
it is well where things are of
sufficient grab
and importance that they wouldn't
reserved that to them they would go to
full council and I think this is another
instance I think that's what mr. Bostic
reason I hope yeah yeah that that's
that's quite honest that's also not you
know that's possible sir yeah I think we
all know that but father if the accretor
correct okay sometimes a committee
report counsel so there are some tweaks
to the recommendation has been put
forward by counsel every citizen or some
additions I should say I lost track this
will go back to the standards committee
to be reviewed as per your original
facial animation with addition that it
would come back to the review committee
before thanked and also there will be an
earlier meeting of the status committee
that's all forward to discuss this
specific issue so it's those three items
and I understand good the general
business is that members are happy with
that chairman of standards is happy for
them John
okay thank you
[Applause]
okay back to seen as a gentler [ __ ] and
hearts of six we have assisted housing
services the tendency in unfortunately
counselor is all tied up
open to test settings approaches
automated members would have had their
fault
so counted to them
I think generally phones economical the
thing working changes it seemed that
mostly changes of its price to
transition perhaps just this baby yeah I
mean I was just going to do it just
saying it's an update on the performance
of the second 450 grant service with
significant focus on the fact that it's
changed from a provider service to know
a new in-house service performance
levels as you can see from the report to
have been maintained in fact there's an
ongoing improving efficiency and as a
result of that because we keep catching
up on efficiencies for the second time
this year that we're going to be spent
and committed probably by the end of
this month so there be prioritised
weightiness again to date the search
today we've received 80 referrals from
the occupational therapy service which
is an ongoing demand which is a proxy
three a week now that might not sound a
lot but of course some of these cases
can be quite complex and take quite a
long time and also believe it or not you
know these cases can take some months
sometimes they can take up to a year or
more so we are still dealing with older
cases as well as newer phones but as the
chairman said the most significant
change and the reason why I brought it
back since October is that the provision
of the service has changed and the
reason for that is I detailed in the
Ries last time in October the Essex
County Council were decommissioning
their housing related services and one
of those home improvement agencies and
as a result Papworth trust throughout
was our provider was decommissioned now
Pat was trust then very late in the day
in February made the business decision
to stop all their home improvement
agencies across their whole business and
to concentrate more on their own
development work so we have to make a
very quick decision on making sure that
we maintain through the cervix bearing
in mind it's a mandatory service with
the administrators of this grant for the
government and we'd already explored
partnering with other local authorities
such as South End which people and was a
bit of a no-go because they had their
own service and one mature enough for us
to partner with them we've already
talked about piloting a service it based
on which we'd already child and again
they at the eleventh hour said no we've
got our own staff members and you can
see that actually we turned that around
and actually provided them staff in the
end but so we were left in a position
where we couldn't have a gap some local
authorities believe you're not in SES
have made that decision have a gap and
as a result following a meeting that I
attended only a couple of weeks ago they
have got very long waiting this and
cannot commit or spend their money but
we made the decision very quickly that
we didn't want a gap and also it was
decided for us in a way because we had
to 2p across to a pad where staff so
we've got a caseworker a DFG disabled
facility chronic caseworker and a
disabled facility gran adaptation
surveyor they sit within the private
housing service within the environmental
health team and actually with added
resilience to the team and private
housing service because the surveyor is
now doing some private housing work and
the caseworker is effectively running
the DFG service with the overview and an
audit or private
so it's a bit longer than I anticipated
but you know if you've got any questions
please let me know counsel mr. Mason
Janus is in part a questioning also
apart advising this committee of
something that I came across while
counselor mrs. Mason I came across them
Louisa Moss is already aware of I know
it's not popular to speak about
sanctuary but I'm going to we came
across a resident who had a leaflet from
sanctuary and these were people who the
family needed some support in terms of
modifications to the home I'll leave it
at that
limit so notice the full story me I
don't wish to identify them but the
leaflet was was of concern because in
indicated in terms of disability
facility grants there's up to seven
hundred and fifteen thousand the
sanctuary would deal with them but over
that you've got to go to vatra District
Council
now I'd previously understood that the
century had a fund of a hundred and
fifty thousand pounds for disability
grants already in their in their budgets
and particularly their gift so I'm
hoping the our budget isn't being raided
by applicants who are being pushed
towards us by sanctuary when indeed
sanctuary should be considering than
themselves
I know Louisa was as concerned about it
as I was and I know that she intends to
raise the matter with century but I
think around this subject as it's here
the committee ought to know what's going
on
was it can I just add to that
just reinforce that you know I agree
where we know every Housing Association
registered provider should be setting
aside money within their own adaptation
policies to meet their own tenants needs
no rot should take quite a hard line on
this through their DFG service and we
have eight registered provider tens
actually on a waiting list because we're
refusing to pay for it through a
disabled facility grant process because
we've gone back to the provider to say
it's your responsibility and if you say
it's not tell us what your policy looks
like for us to evidence that you don't
have any money etc so just to reassure
council mr. Mason that that case is
quite case specific but on a general
note we do not pay by Housing
Association tenants to have adaptation
works done and and you know every case
has to be looked at individually but at
today's this year we haven't paid for
any okay thank you so can I come back on
that if the reason I want to come back
is because obviously I was meeting with
a resident who had the same three
leaflets and told me that's the way I've
worked it was it was obviously not the
case and I found it very difficult to
turn around and say to them well I'm
sorry but whatever they say is incorrect
and this is how it is so I'd like to be
assured that some Romanian action is
being taken by sanctuary and any other
Housing Association that's indicating
there should come to us and just please
break up yeah
we have a partnership meeting later on
this month and it's on my agenda and
I've already asked them to amend the
leaflet so we're going to have to ask
for confirmation of that at the
partnership meeting okay thank you very
much
okay was amazing thank you very much
councillor quite it's quite interesting
that terms cancel make some raise that
matter because it's just reminded me of
something in relation to one of our
residents that they breach sanctuary one
of the person who's living in the
household he's deteriorating condition
and that they're looking for adaptation
or possibly moving to a more appropriate
dwelling and I shoot up update myself of
their situation because as far as I'm
aware this they still haven't had either
happen and this is a matter that's
ongoing for months and even two years so
I don't know if access to a situation
where thankfully might be dragging their
feet we've been I'm hoping that
something else might happen but I I'm
going to have to personally sort of a
lot to find out what their current
situation is and see what what is
actually happening with with that
particular issue wasn't no original
question I was gonna ask the original
question that I wanted to answer is that
it would seem that your money that you
get for the ROM covers you for six
months and then you're just sort of like
treading water for the final six months
is that you
is this way is year-on-year or is that
which way which way is it going that's
reported because you know performance
was a good previously and we increased
performance and as result we are
catching up now on getting people
through quicker and of course we're
spending things quicker that
unfortunately doesn't happen overnight
we're now in a second year we're still
in that scenario but she write to say
we're getting to six months seven months
and I also had a top-up of capital
grants and I'll be putting forward an
application for further capital money is
for next year to support us you know
whether that's approved or not another
thing so I would I have to be realistic
to say that we'll probably got another
year another full year of possibly you
know waiting is going forward and
because the demand is not decreasing
yeah thank you thank you
I'll see Teresa you just mentioned that
you've got eight so clients on there
from housing associations are they look
the same housing association so how many
are
oh sorry if is a widespread problem
isn't a specific problem to one and I
know that last year we've run out of
resources so that we have a waiting list
the people on the waiting list that will
last you know they're sitting still
ending on the waiting list from last
year so from that point of view we have
cleared last year's waiting live
I mean there's no waitress at the moment
obviously we're looking at every case
very closely everyone that's on the
waiting is previous have off see all
gone through the system now and those
who do become on a waitress eventually
are prioritized according to need and
then looked at again should they need
change
Thank You Chancellor Stanley Thank You
chairman just a couple of pointers
really that I'd like to know how is as
this home improvement services has been
discontinued then I'd like to know just
how much pressure you can apply to the
perhaps the others or that of the people
that are involved in getting these
modifications done to the premises and
what's profession can you apply today to
the the fact that you've got 750 750
pounds that is the limit I think or
something you thought that what you're
talking about and if that person doesn't
it's somewhat saying to that person that
this is the way it works or that's the
way it was this person still within the
middle trying to get the work done how
much pressure can you apply to get that
work done either a through a secretary
or somebody like that for any Housing
Association
it's refusing to carry out the works we
just have to take it case-by-case I mean
ultimately everyone's got the right to
apply for a mandatory disabled facility
grant if they're manageable and you know
we don't like to see the client stuck in
the middle because it is about the
client at the end of the day so we're
just what could I say we put as much the
pressure we ask for their adaptation
policy we ask for evidence suspend a
commitment against their budget we look
at the client's needs or balance the
load of things up and you know we see
what route we take at the moment we
haven't taken a DFG route and we've got
like few cases done through how the
Association of zoos on so you know I can
put as much pressure as I can I'm not
too sure we'll have to answer it ready I
mean that was a specific law I was just
thinking about them while you're
discussing all of this this person is in
the middle with if it takes I don't know
what foot length of time it is but it
does seem to me that whilst you're doing
throwing this person is stuck in the
meeting there because their lives are
not getting any better and finally it
doesn't you know I mean what I was
thinking all these that perhaps there's
a mediation there where you can say to
whatever hazard Association it is let's
get this job done whatever and then
we'll sort there at the finances often I
get to the stage where we might come to
an impasse as you say you'd never want
the clients will await more than you
know several months because some of them
are critically fullest critical need if
it's a basic bathing need or a tourist
you need you
- way up and some circumstance with some
local authorities make it the decision
across all house associations to do 50
percent grant fifty percent from the
house Association we're just taking a
hard line and say no we don't want you
because our budget is so limited and
we're spending it so for some cases we
do come to compromise but it's very few
I have to say and it doesn't mean
clients just wait there forever for
things to be done you know we keep
monitoring it I think the one that's
been on Alice the longest is two months
my other question really is the new
officers that you've got where you say
that one of them is it still with the
private housing when you say primary
mean exactly what I said is the DFG
adaptation survey was handled in the
private housing service private housing
officer is one that deals with private
tenant landlord abuses so for example
having a surveyor resource is quite
useful so when a tenant might ring us
and say we've got some repairs needed
often we might send a surveyor out to go
and have a look and make an assessment
because he's actually trained to do what
we call housing health rating housing
health rating safety inspections thank
you thank you thank you firstly I just
want to note for the record there is no
equality and diversity implications on
this report unfaithful they need to be
medications given ex disabled facilities
groans I don't understand for mr. pahst
operators being added to the form at the
future I do know the right to do have
that on and the description underneath
which is fair enough probably expecting
you try I thought that was just for
noting moving on I did also have the
same questioners and caster Stanley and
it does concern me that there may be
people for we between us and century
where we can't foresee I do take your
point that the longest they have waited
is two months but even then if they need
the facilities is still quite difficult
for them and also understand that it's
not your sanctuary and sank trees the
one where we have committee members do
we do you speak to a committee members
to make sure they're aware of this
because surely the committee members or
secretary would have some power to
actually get them to spend the 150,000
pounds appropriately is that part of
what we're doing I mean today you know
I've got two central cases on the list I
haven't had a need to go to committee
members and I agree that would be a way
forward but actually we're talking quite
actually essentially all about these two
cases and I talked to them apart it
maintains about days on ok but the other
ones other we've done as a senior
situation the other one so yeah just
does concern me but do tell me what I
must do man so you know we do propose
actually to have a going off piece of it
and register provider forum to talk
about a range of things and to get
officers around the table and that would
be one of the agenda items we need to
talk about which is our approach to
several facilities grants and how we
manage that going forward so clients
don't get caught in the middle and have
to wait
when you left aliens funding may be
moving on from um slightly is where we
may be unable to up to provide the wrong
because either end money's running out
or it's not super cool or they'd open
their criteria are we able to quit
people in the direction of other grants
which may be available to minority to
have a resident about a year or so ago
who was pointed in the direction which I
think he found himself through the sure
knows how makes mom do something about
that something else and are we able to
do that and to help people to some
extent with that if in the last six
months of the year we have no money
are we able to put people where they
make it remember yeah yeah of course I
mean it
sometimes it's not about even being able
to some people have the means test
because we're administrators of this
process to detected by government and
the means test if that doesn't if people
aren't me to the means test again we
have to sign post them as you rightly
say there's suffer this British Legion
the Salvation Army we've also got a
suggested builders list where they are
very competitive in the way of course
choices there it is difficult because
these adaptations average you know 11
active shower averages about four
thousand pounds that's a lot of money
but often people can named pieces of
equipment and also we would often advise
people to go back to occupational
therapy to see if there's any other
equipment that they can have to mean
they mean short-term things
just two points really when you're
talking about the the average is 21
weeks people wait that's fondly be given
the process to the actual completion of
the work so that's partly outside of our
control it's the whole DFG journey so I
recognize it is the day the client you
know the we get the occupational therapy
refer to the day that the worse
completed he's got loads of dependencies
on it and you've even more out of
control than it used to be because you
can see from the report that we're
making it much more self-serve so it's
up to the client to get the estimate
cetera so these are two more that which
we may not have to do because really may
just how efficient we are in that how
quickly we process our part of this well
to tell you if that's something we need
to improve on I mean in now step-by-step
procedures we talked about the housing
applications if they are going out in 15
working days and doing the cost of what
go and do the cost check-in within 15
working days and I think we can tighten
up to say how quickly our caseworker
would go out if they choose to have our
casework help fill out the forms so I do
recognize that something we can tighten
up on but again you know it will depend
the whole 21 weeks will depend a bit
mostly on the client area you want the
other stuff which there the other how
the other in final point but the moment
is around three point nine the find is
revealed that ninety eight percent of
customers are very satisfied with one
outcome complete adaptations
you've seen I think ninety eight percent
is quite good I'll break it out of 90
percent psychosis all the time we're not
on the border century and and it wasn't
a ninety-eight assemblage I recognized
when talking to tenants there so I'm a
bit doubt about the night saying first
of all we're saying that light erickson
of those surveyed at the end of the
process there
survey people who haven't completed
process from sips no process to complete
course and we've run out of money I
think the reason is do we have we
thought that journey might be all set I
mean University I think to a certain
extent though you can see that we're
already recognizing our customer
satisfaction the way we measure English
to be improved especially around
outcomes and that 98% you know I smile
with you because really at the moment
they're cruelly saying are you happy
with your adaptations but of course
you're going to be on it because I was
so independent with increased you know
no disrespect that should be a hundred
percent rather ninety-eight if we're
meeting the need rightly this is more
about outcomes as you rightly say watch
your journey being like have you made in
a long time have you been informed
throughout the process so that's the
kind of thing that I want to improve it
by which is a bit early mapping I
suppose because we need to know how how
we're doing in the way of information
whether they're self-serve processes
worked you know did it take a long time
would you like more help in this that
and the other and also we need to find
out from them you know has it reduce
your force your dependency on family and
things like that we're not asking those
questions or we'll also get the moment
because to tell the true six months on
we've just been concentrating on getting
this service right is unhappy with the
adaptations with the course you are
because you've got to the end of your
journey and all of a sudden you've
forgotten perhaps how long you might
have taken now I'm not saying it's taken
long but you know that's it and also I'm
happy with the contracts which I think
it's important one because we've carried
forward the contractors from patent
mirth we've built up new relationships
with them so yeah they're taking a point
we do need to improve on
and a bit of journey mapping will happen
did you catch them in yo the resident
who's had planning from Papworth trust
approved products of these changes the
building work hasn't been done yet
so they've got member of their family
they require another toilet downstairs
and some I presume that's something the
council will pick up because nothing's
happened as months ago and it all went
through the planning process okay I mean
it would be a planning process but all
Papworth cases so now with us only now
control so if you want to speak to me
afterwards all well if he wants to
follow up I'll tell him clearly a couple
of questions just about some details in
the report and three point five it says
over the last six months watching the
supportive programs reinstated to the
surveying work generates a new pump it
can be recycled back into the local
deity project have you are you able to
say how much income at the moment that
income is approximately five thousand
pound
also 5.3 talks about the basic area fund
and it said there VCF allocation energy
work has increased over the last two
years and there is a commitment to
further increase this in 2018 2019
do we know what that increase will be I
wish already we don't know unfortunately
it was really late last year it was
around about may time and we've got no
confirmation it's going to be any
earlier this year so I might not know as
they just made I know it will be the
same as this year if not a bit higher
and you'd probably be about $20,000 okay
if it is 20,000 hi I'm food
last year we because 20,000 like me I
thank you very much cancer spending
Thank You chairman just came back to the
21 weeks which is a lot of time for
somebody to say not only great leads but
a way of life that is getting
detrimental e worse for them hat when
that you own they're asking for them to
do something most of the work itself and
if they are if they've got somebody who
looks after them what their wife or
their husband something they won't have
much time really to do this so how much
intervention does the cancer actually
put me in that 21 weeks because 21 weeks
is it's it's a big job for somebody
that's really sort of trying to make
each of these is they are not getting
any younger
if you know what are they just had file
the council are taking 21 weeks that's
the whole process and it varies from
client to client but clearly if a client
is not capable or hasn't got a
capability or they're in crisis then the
caseworker that's the whole point steps
in initially holds their hand throughout
the journey and will help them with
estimates fill out forms etc I'm not
saying that it's going to reduce it
significantly reduce the pressures of
the family although I see self-serve
most clients take up that option but if
not we step in immediately and help
and that really is filling out quite
complex forms and all the forms that go
with it and particularly to help them
get estimates but not to you know just
help them through the process and if you
are the occupants don't don't understand
what they ask him for let alone what
they're reading in I agree there are
some cases most than you say sometimes
have family friends I want to control
you and that's absolutely what should
happen really so probably do you look at
me Thank You counsel mr. Seville you
just like to ask a question I'm not sure
this comes under our auspices that but
school but it is something that affects
the residents that applying for these
grants we tend to come in as I
understand it when we get the OT report
what concerns me is possibly the length
of time before someone's name is there
and the OT assessment and the report
breaches do we have any idea how long
that part of the journey is I know it's
before it comes to us but you're
anywhere long story makes it significant
and at the moment the occupation forever
sir mr. Vallee doctors tell me there's
no way just so clients that are ringing
out through social care are then being
obviously referred into the OT hub and
then picked up you know I think you're
probably talking average five to ten
working days was this seen
they've got equipment to do it within 20
working days and tell you around to us
but during that time don't forget you
know the occupational therapist would
have probably asked for equipment for a
media critical need and there's lots of
cases that don't come to my sit same for
major adaptations but are going
thank you I just want to write one thing
it's a total century they say that they
sort they only go up to 750 pounds is
that right all right and then for the
rest I can't remember what he said in
the knee forget what 17 it's very
surprising you know secretaries annual
turnover was 299 million pounds last
year and that's all that can find
he's 750 pounds yeah it to me that just
dunk it's not right you know to to mess
these paper about send them to Philip
house and in the end his Rockford's that
got by for the the operations that's it
did I understand you're home to meeting
the sanctuary on this when obviously you
know I'm on the committee and there's
750 pounds top you mentioned there told
you say anything as I've seen so you
know what there seems a lot so it's not
right honest so I haven't seen it sir
perhaps we could deliver it
I've 72 Louisa moss and she can provide
you with a copy I didn't say that John I
do the same I didn't believe it I just
said I hadn't seen it and why she said
was press Luiza clarify when we go to
get some meeting with same place yeah
it's it's quite as you say it's correct
for sanctuary and it's quite a common
approach from our registered providers
yeah I mean it was just update on the
use of the powers of the last year of
which they've been no uses and also just
to show following the review there's
been some name changes around a
responsible officer which is now myself
and authorised officers and also the
Commissioner the commissioners
restructured and renamed itself and
that's been acknowledged as a relief use
thank you Jim
nothing this gets right through quickly
doesn't it I just actually quiz man all
just mentioned the policies on diversity
implications again because I'm going to
mention every meeting I go to whether
it's not doesn't it be able thank you it
should be noted I was looking through
the report right I've actually kept not
one of the paragraphs onyx rice probably
the main feelings was about was we don't
separate under own
covert human etcetera sources vulnerable
young people where I've noticed that
other councils with a prefer policy do
and they and they mention a bit
particularly and raise the point that
normally their chief executive in their
instance would be all would be the
person who should be authorizing any of
those sir surveys almost worthy for it
now any of those investigations I think
that would be a suitable amendment to a
policy that where any young wonderful
person is involved if the authorization
be with the other system territory
should be with a militant director Kim
nine just come in there we do not use
young people there's cheese's then we
should say that in the policy is not
clear do those investigation Center
County that's that's fine but yeah but
no as I understand reading it young
people can be for instance if if you've
got a young person checking where the
picture of setting fundraising but but
it's not not necessarily I think it's
quite confusing about different ones are
frayed and I think you should be much
clearer in here that we do not use young
people think but do we use wonderful
people could there be us how do you know
that women weepers and we we should
psyche psyche women actually used cheesy
to told we don't actually use but we
have a policy either an OPM equality but
so that you don't are on our statutory
Jews I mean we certainly can amend it if
that's what members want I mean it's
passed scrutiny by the Aleutians in the
last it is happy to be corrected but
reading these policies they're not
blessing Sony's
the cheese for the work to the working
you do as well I use that one maybe a
young person about something else such
as the underage it's not an
investigation into them themselves but
they're the person being used as well
yeah which is the case there so we need
to say that we will not use I think the
party needs to state if we're not going
to use them we do not use young people
or we do not use wonderful people yeah
or if we do use them they must go
through elementary director young people
okay thank you for thank you for that I
was also going that was important
actually but I was also just checking
through invalid the people we have all
the appendix we we we have mentioned
them in our annex so we're at all or a
number of empanada the number of
councils don't mention by name they'll
thrive applicants in the documents we
seem to have they seem to be happy to
report them throughout the years as
needed we same time a lot of
environmental health people authorized
which presumably is around potential
waste disposals
departments they simply pop when also p3
is plateau of stuff which the
environment would be involved in I'm
surprised because one of the areas older
thought we would
or it could use is it benefit for all
not a see any benefit officers down is
there a reason
or carried out by the DWP right now this
one doesn't have any four teams that's
all being taken but is there a reason
for the increase in the number of
authorized that because it's building
that money but you just want enough
people there that there might be people
available it's a process we don't seem
to use with you same terms of awful lot
of people with rised just based on the
new staff the establishment listen if we
need them there ends
[Music]
I think it's in Dublin you will notice
there wasn't a teacher sitting document
this month the for planning and policy
documents have been removed that will
now be going through the plans planning
policy subcommittee which i think is
right
members wondering information to that
there was an item the members wanted for
the assistant director planning to come
to the committee to talk about those
documents I'll put it on for next month
is that still required
counselor and if I could speak to this
because I've thought about it a little
more perhaps I mean obviously the reason
we raised it here is because we are the
scrutiny committee and it would have
appeared from where we were sitting and
indeed I am a member of the flying
policy subcommittee and I hadn't heard a
thing and nor did counselor why it was
perfectly reasonable and understandable
for us to or as a committee to ask for
an update and for serious appropriately
but of course things have certainly been
superseded by action which I suppose in
many senses is what we want is happen so
these reports and indeed all the other
evidence and has probably a list that
goes on for at least 2024 significant
documents have all got to be reviewed by
the planning policy subcommittee and as
I mentioned earlier there will be a
training session in November so that all
members of the council can appreciate
what these evidence documents are and
what the implications are of them even
before the matter gets to name policy
and more particularly to support Council
and there is a full council to consider
this especial for Council 28th of
November and Ingrid
I've reflected also on the status of the
planning policy subcommittee I've I've
come to the conclusion and this comes
back to something I was talking about
earlier that it's a committee of four
council and if that is the case and as
indeed it reported in June has a
committee of for Council to full council
and of course it becomes a decision of
four Council which in itself is not
something that scrutiny can actually
undertake so I'm not sure at this
and what role I hope you overview and
scrutiny or review committee would play
in the loop plan process anyway and I'd
finally to provide either mr. boss
welcome still here or mr. garre's to
comment on that and whether I'm correct
having looked into it and also discuss
the matter with my colleague yes you are
correct as I suspected yesterday it is a
committee of board counsel and they
recommending to counsel and therefore
the scrutiny doesn't come into it and I
would imagine that it may be of interest
to review if the process is failing in
some respect or another then it may be
of interest to review but I think if the
process it goes forward as as planned
and shoot it should be should be
accepted wonderful yes if I may be
chairman comments without they're the
only time I think some review committee
might so but it's hand up is if at some
stage the government in any way
suggested that we were from behind of
the curve and therefore behind their
expectations or the revision of the
local plan I think we have to bear in
mind that the requirement of the
inspector in 2011 was that we would
undertake an early revision of the core
strategy which is now terms a local plan
they're in several consultants who have
commented that Rochford may fall into a
supervisory situation that our officers
are confident that won't happen but if
it did happen that I think review
committee would be the appropriate place
to take charge of it because clearly
planning policy committee as a committee
of form Council would have failed to do
its job and for council itself probably
five as well so I think those would be
the circumstances when something would
happen members any other comments moving
on to agenda item on the chambers of
work and anybody needs a copy
if we look at the center November very
much they are gonna cross out the bottom
one the planting policy key decisions
thankfully Hanson coming to talk about
their progress on the three hundred and
then building control and enforcement of
an unauthorized adverts then there's
also couple of or we have the ICT review
that's booked in for a meeting at the
end of October 23 and we're still read a
book one another Constitution and
darling sort out the treasury management
advices good
best of times I might open to be you
wouldn't you non the ICT - my so
remember that our would have been sent
kind of work